(electronic music)
(tropical music)
(gulp)
- Too much honey.
- Oh my gosh, does that
guy have a fidget spinner?
(epic music)
- What the hell?
That's so lame.
- Yeah, you would never catch
me with a fidget spinner.
- I don't get the appeal.
(epic music)
- Me neither!
They're just stupid toys.
- What's the point?
(epic music)
- Are they supposed to help you focus;
'cause I think they're crazy distracting?
- It's such a dumb trend.
(epic music)
- These things are getting
in the way of everything.
- I'm so sick of them.
- If I have to see another video
about a fidget spinner, I'm gonna lose it.
- Grown adults trying
so hard to be relatable.
- Are fidget spinners supposed
to help you concentrate,
because it's definitely not working.
- I'm not even that relaxed.
- Fidget spinners need to end.
- Death to fidget spinners!
(epic music)
(electronic music)